it there's there's a difference in our
life it's hard to understand i think for
other people legitimate people don't
understand it and this is why i'm trying
to do
in my scripted show
i i'm doing a scene that i go after
another
hiccup
an older very very experienced hit guy
i'm young
i'm a guy already
but not a pimple on his ass
they picked me to go after
because
they feel that this guy who's very very
smart very sharp very cunning
will underestimate me
you will underestimate my
looks i look young
i'm supposed to be
he's told or jerk off a guy who brings
messages
and sammy i think could pull this off
and uh this is the head-on johnny keys
and i
i did
i snatched them
when i had them in the truck in a van
he looked at me and said
a punk
a jerk-off
a messenger
with five families in new york and the
philadelphia family
couldn't do
you did
you have me sitting in this van
it was the most amazing [ __ ] thing i
ever heard
now
when we do this
i don't want to do it in my movie where
i just shoot him
or vice versa
the people
who want to make it known what went
through his head
and what went through my head
they're going to see
what made both of us tick
not just shoot them up gang them and
doing this and doing that
it's going to be different
he talked to me in the van
he said
you're good
you're really good
you're [ __ ] up a little bit
okay what'd i do
he said look at the windows
truckers
they have these cbs they'll look in this
window
they'll see me
tied up
they'll see you they'll see these other
guys they'll call the cops
i was thinking he's critiquing him
i'm looking at him and i'm saying to my
i say a word
but i'm saying to myself
he's telling me
how to do a hit
on himself
you know more cops involved
the [ __ ] kind of guy do i got here
then he tells me
we're talking like we are
saying
going in my pocket i got pills in here
what kind of pills
nitroglycemic pills
i have pains in my chest and i want to
die of a heart attack
i go in his pocket
as i take the man out he says put one
under my tongue
if i don't get better put one another
one every five minutes
i put one in his mouth
now i'm saying to myself
you don't want to die of a heart attack
he's about to die he knows it
you don't want to dive on thing
we talk
i get to know him
i fall in love with him
i love him more than any [ __ ] man on
the planet
he's
he
he's what my fear is about he's what
goes in austria is about
he showed me how to die
like a man
later on he says
sammy i want two favors more
what
the guy who pulls the trigger
if it's not you
let it be a friend of ours meaning a
maid guy
you got it
and take my shoes off
why do you want me to take your shoes
off
he says
i told my wife she knew i was in this
life
she knew there was a war that broke out
in philadelphia
i told my wife i'll die with my shoes
off don't worry about it
meaning he'll be home with his shoes off
he's not gonna die in the street
i said that's pretty heavy stuff
bro he said
she'll know
i was thinking about her
in my final minutes
of life
and i didn't want to kill this guy
it broke my [ __ ] heart
what kind of guy is this
but i had i was under orders
i did kill him
nikki scott from won the war
for what i did
the next day i drove to paul's house
it was done it was in the papers that uh
heavyweight mobster by the name of
johnny keys
was found in staten island and dumps
that
with no shoes
when i went to paul's house the maid let
me in paul got up and came running over
grabbed me
you did it
i didn't answer
he said what's the matter
i said what i did last night
i killed
what my fear is about what goes in
austria is about
what where about he should have been the
boss not nick
i'm not happy about it
i feel dirty
he said
anybody else will be jumping up and down
they're going to know our family
took care of it
every boss every under boss and every
console he has
gonna know
that you did it
nikki's gonna know he won the war
and you did it
and you're disturbed
yeah
i don't give a [ __ ] what they think
he said to me sammy don't change
stay like that
grammy hugged me kiss me let me go i
don't want to talk about this no mom of
course
it [ __ ] wrecks me thinking about him
and he taught me how to die i always
wondered
if my time comes from ever in a van
my last minute
whether it's a hit guy whether it's
cancer whatever the [ __ ] it is could i
die like this guy
could i be him
i hope so you know you never begged you
to change your mind never tried to talk
you out of it he tried to do one thing
once
at the end he said sammy i have a lot of
money i can make you a very wealthy man
i said please john
don't do that
i've developed a tremendous [ __ ]
respect for you
you told me this is good enough so i'm
telling you it is ghosts and rush
there's no money in the [ __ ] world
that's going to stop me
and don't do it don't even say it
they smiled
you all goes in austria true and through
racketeers
don't do that
thugs mafiosos
gangsters they do that he was a gangster
there's a difference
going back to the original question
there's a difference in the stories
about making money
and about that there's no money in the
[ __ ] world
and the respect i have
then
the love i'm not ashamed to say i love
another man i don't not in that way but
in the respect i have
and i
i talk about it on my podcast
and uh it's actually
it sounds like a commercial so i'm not
even going to say it what part of the
it's it's on my podcast
and uh
it's an incredible thing
and to me it was
a lesson in goes and ushered that i
that i learned
that is the most amazing thing in the
[ __ ] world
and i about life
about life
[Music]
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]